エンディング
トミー、いるの?
アキラ
私はごめんなさい、トミー。
なぜ?
私、わざとトミーにつらくあたっていたの。
そうすることで、トミーが発奮してくれるなら、あの三人に勝ってくれるならと。
トミー、私を許してください。
大丈夫。私は大丈夫。
トミー、私のこと、嫌いになった。
オー、ジーザス。僕が君を…
トミー!アイラブユー、トミー!
こ、これは夢か?
考えてみたら、アキナちゃんがバニーガールの衣装を着てるわけないし。
夢とは分かれば、目が覚めないうちに早いとこ!
やっちめー!
それは、ヒントです!
お疲れ様でーす!
これでしっぽんぽんだもんね
ひどいぞ
起きるぞ
起きる前に責任取ってくんの
悪い夢を見たぜ
頭が爆裂してんな
あれほどまでに裏切られても
俺はまだアキナのことを忘れられないのか
旅に出るか
いきなりこんな最果ての土地に来ちまったぜ
旅の方でございますだが
忘れていた自分を取り戻すのさ
海見るだい
男はそたらとき海見るのが一番だ
平安
ええ
みんな俺の醸し出す雰囲気にビビったようだぜ
早くドアスマイバー
ああ、冷たい冷たい
そしたらどこにいたら寒いんでねえかい
あ、す、すみません
二頭身の体さ、トレンチコートなんか着て似合ねえな、田舎臭くて
あのひんそな顔つき、あれはきっといいかもにちげえねえづら。
ごはちの、ごちさく。
いやさ、あんちはこっちのでぃがまっていいけ。
こっちさござってけらっしゃいような。
こっつのみんつはあみぃづらでぃ。
生まれついてのアイドル性ってやつか。
どこへ行っても人気の的だぜ。
じゃ、このメンツに入れてもらおうか。
うわあああああ
よりによって何だめだ
このジャンスを最強のメンバー
いろいろ3人集のタッグに入った
水割のうつき
ホッピーのトウバラ
そしてハイサワーのゲント
この3人
一見ただのアルチューに見える
実はいずれも
都を打ちしたプロジャンス達であった
志は捨てていたが まだまだ打ち筋は素人の日ではなかった
汚い捨て牌だなぁ
ハッターピンク高め急ピンで3色ドライチ こんな連中ならすぐ出ると思うが
まずは玉だな
ヨーク帰捕
どこのコメントになるへろ
一応まだ投げてます
ここだ
初期 普通のトイッター
茎誇り ソレ
どうもありがとうございました
挙句
飲んだ
strong
めこけてしまったな
計画を維持しているからだ
泣いている
キューピーをきました
お
我が家も
何 wall down
脳の状態
孤独で
マイ職者は
眠っている
警 prank
ちょっと
一併
強い
つえ
おい、豊臣
い、いねだ
おーい
こんなところに置き手紙が
やろう、置き手紙なんかしてきやがって
オラたちから逃げるつもりだな
なさけねえやつ
豊臣くん
で、なんて書いてあるんだ
おい、早見
どこ行くんだ
豊臣くん!
明菜ちゃんね。しばらくの間、北へ旅打ちに出ます。
どこへ行っても、君のことは忘れません。豊臣。
早見!
慎太郎くん。
もう俺を、慎太郎さんとは呼んでくれねぇのか?
私…
オレを残して行くつもりだな
ご、ごめんなさい、やっぱり私
言うな!
そうか、オレに近づいたのはトヨトミの奴を発奮させるためだったってわけか
オレを、オレを利用してたのか!
えっと、襟足はこんなもんでいいかな
あ、右切りすぎちゃった、あ、左切りすぎちゃった、あ、だってだってめちゃくちゃなっちゃった
オレを
俺を利用してたのか
ごめんなさい
でも
私行きます
まもなく14時40分発特別急行
雪椿32号北国行きが
14番ホームより発車いたします
me
none
老朽 shut
ん
ain't you
me
dee
豊臣くん、あたしが行くまで
どんだ、ちゅんだ、どらどら、ばかだべ
豊臣くん、がんばって
あたしが行くまで、けして、けして箱はわらないでね
急げ、アキラ
トヨタビの箱は近い
豊臣くん、しっかりね。
私が着くまで、耐えるのよ。
早く起来や。
一昼までも考えで寝てばよ。
単品三食。
春には貼ったが。
かといってドラはスーピー
親のリーチに一発でドラそばのサブローピンは切れない
仕方ない
ここは耐えがたきを耐え忍びがたきを忍び
タイヤをのみに落としてもウーピン斬りだ
リーチ一発メンホン一通
ズガーン
おやっぱねだな
なんだよ、またでっけえのふんだこだよ
もう家帰る、もうやめろ
まんた用事退行したって
甘かすぎて出た
ちょっと待っててください、すぐに戻ります
確かに、ババ君だった
よく考えてみれば、ババ君のことは何一つ知らなかった
一体何者だったのか
トヨトミがババのことをただの唇お化けではないかと思うようになったのは
それからしばらくたってからである
さて東京に帰るか
帰んねえねえこの
ほれほれほれまだ2曲残ってるぞ
出す出す
この町だわ。この町から彼の声が聞こえてくる
こっちだわ
近いわ
あれはツカンポの花
ここにも、あそこにも、ここにも
ここだわ
ドヨタミック
アキナちゃん
どうしてここがわかったの
それは
それはアイユ
アキダちゃーん
ヌユトミック
お客さん静かに打ってほしいズラ
うちは紳士的な店ズラで
あのね、あのね、おじちゃんたちが僕をいじめるんだよ
よしよし、もう大丈夫
はい、チンして
この続き、私が代わりに入っていいかしら
都会もはマナーちゅうもんも知らねえぞらからよ
どうやらええけども
その人さ
ハコスタ20万って紛れんど
え?そんなに?
しかも、もう終わらせないべ。
キャン!何すんのよ!
やめろ、やめて、痛い痛い。
ほら、早まんでね。
このまま行けば、この娘子だけかもしんねぇべよ。
だなぁ。
とにかく、連チャンするしかないわね。
そりゃあ、相手に連チャンスが。
そりは、百万里剣で上がるよか、難しいねの。
いいピン、カン。
おっと、数カンつかや。
ローソー、カン。
グダズ、カンステ、テイルズ、バラバラガー。
ダメ。
こいつも、カンだったでしてな。
カン!
あら。
やだ、またカン。
どっちを切ろうかな。
こっち。
どいつば切ればいいんだ。
やんそば最後まで持ってんだら、いっそは危ねえべす。
といといすこうで真ん中のパイは早めに捨ててる。
ほしたれば、この辺は、ねえ。
あら。
え?
よかったわ。それらん。
リアンスオートパーソン
キャー!見て見て!
リアンスオートパーソンのひっかけなの!
はーい!
まんずまんず、こっつづっここっつづっこ
犬に噛まれたようなもんだべす
次に流せばいいでねえろうな
うつきはタイヤを
トウバラはシロのみ
うーん
ダブルー
ケントは一巡目リーチ
ぐぐぐ
やったー
これで完璧に流れたべ
バイケバイケ
イガッタイガッタイガッタ
みんなラッキーよね
当たり牌避けてるもんね
ふっ
て、テンパってんのかや
ねや
ツーワンか。これは切れないわ。
ツーワンカン!
ピンフタンヤオサンショクドラドラなのに、もったいないね。
キャ!積もった!
タンズモウリンシャンサンピンガカンドラデドラサン!
なんだ結局親パネに戻ったんだ
人の当たり牌返して出す牌の不安積もってか
ちぃぽんろん
さあやっと8本馬よ
次から何を上がっても役満だね
はい、リーチ!
ごめんなさい。
リーチ一発、メンチン。
えっと、ウラさん。
やだーどうせ役マンなのにメンチンでしかもウラさんよ
もったいねー
こうしてトウバラは死んだ
もっと運を節約しなきゃ
飲み手でいいんだよ飲み手で
観念してからー
やだまた
ロンタイヤオ三色イーペイコー
もったいねー!
こうして、ゲントは死んだ。
どうして、こっせぇ!
ほ、本当に無駄だわ!
本当に無駄だね!
じゅんちゃん、ドラさん!
かぁー!もったいねー!
こうして、ウツキは死んだ。
勝負の後のタバコがやけに苦いぞ。
おうち帰りたーい でもおうちがわからない
子供帰り現象だわ
ふんっ 困ったやつらだ
お金もなーい
ごめんなさいね 豊臣くん
もう済んだことさ 気にするなよ
また会ったな 爺さん
旅の人 探しもんは見つかりやしたかな
ああ 俺の中で何かが変わったような
帰りましょう 東京へ
ありがちなラストカットとともに
二人を乗せた列車は一路東京へと帰って行くのであった
ここで一句
白の実は悲しからずや
カビ茶の青
シム茶の春にも泣かず漂う
おそ松
一首奏伝 幻の究極打法
泣く子も振り込むその必殺技
無花粉打法をひっさげ
トヨトミ君は帰ってきた
次回 恐怖の無花粉打法
トヨトミの逆襲
きっと見てね
眠っちゃいや
お疲れ様でした
ご視聴ありがとうございました
やりづいて 勝手飲み越すビールがうまい
スカッと 男は命がけ
スカッと スカッと ガキカメと ガガンガンの色
ご視聴ありがとうございました